ви я як президент естонії чогось жадає
руси usa грози і для вашої україни я
думаю що такі аспекти поєдинку Росії
до суті агресивні там може заподіяти і
проблемам я недавно чата в рахунку гурову
було зафіксовано 266 польотів
російських чи ризикових таким і світло
включеним та транспондерами в team я
navajo ще кримські сценарій можна
повторити есе ми йшли в тему випуску
росії pd про ти країни члена нато війни
одноразового rhino для національності
естонії
у троянди міні русі і ваша на заручниць на
праворуч і щоб нас правді змінив і
покровителя за рсн сша чому ж майк
окраїна ніби по страшних вона закладена
чого наповнена нехай і навпаки я нехай
над державу то слідує її і курсом ми не
з вини боратин над державами ми
добровільно пригнав і сяду з чудово
середнє право одружуватися мікро і з нами та
базанова на позиції 100 США раз ходіть у
багатих харчування ми в основному досліджуємо
біля лінії з Джордж Кеннан написав
я їжі ваш сусід росія то ви можете
будь то обидва васали обаму рогами і я
проводжу проблемою у Росії це вчити
обидві держави васали обидві держави вороги
україна ви вирішила подбаєш у
решту за ніжність та відра see you
тремтіння стала купою ти ж самий вид
балуйся з грузія глумовичу про україну
поважає і ви, і такий ще на вигляд було
ciak держава про іпре на не вразити
його нею обожнюю рахунок зараз ти на
російську льодову пропаганду я пам'ятаю
як на формі брюсселі 2014 року
відразу після анексії крима посол Росії
по 2 cd іржаві ще на вигляд голосі
держави ще на вигляд класі з приводу скроні
бога потенціалу україни хлопець
нашими країнами ми поженешся
ситуація не душа dobra а особі
демократична держава зсувними та
чесними виборами
знаючим рим нам корупцією
Україна видозмінюється це відра в одному
у to my chest не те вільний вибір і ви
нижчому так олігархи корупція
душогуба ляльки країни та до заливних
корупції прибуваю на 126 місії заново
чий україну ще знаходиться зацем поки
знайомий на сто сорок четвертому біля місії в
тому з чого даний вид булочок держава
через корупцію ви майже ломоносова
яка smack my file